Welcome everybody to another Zoom call, or I do my best to answer your questions.
If you did not get a question submitted, remember you submit those questions on the members
site.
So, your full member, just go on the member site, submit those questions on any of the pages.
You'll see Zoom call question box that you can hit, just type it in and hit submit.
But if you think of a question when you're on here, go ahead and type it in the chat right
there.
And we'll try to answer it as soon as we get through these questions.
We only have five or six questions that were submitted.
So this will be a short Zoom call, and it's type in some questions.
Also remember that on the member site are all the announcements of anything new.
The last one of the announcements this week is last week Zoom call failed to record something
happened with Zoom.
It's only happened a few times, but sometimes there's a staff who is with Zoom and then it
doesn't get records, but it won't convert and it loses all the data.
So I apologize for that.
So if you were able to be on last week and you missed a question, make sure you ask it again.
So let's get to the questions first question.
If a person is using the right machine for Lyme disease, why do they react so severely
and what should they do to prevent works reactions?
So a Herc cyber reaction is a reaction because you are reacting to the die off of a bacteria.
So with grab negative bacteria like Borrelia burgundorphy, it has lipopolysaccharides in the cell
membrane of that bacteria.
And then when you kill it, it liberates those lipopolysaccharides and lipopolysaccharides
can damage the blood barrier across the blood barrier and cause inflammation in the brain.
If you already have primed microglial cells, you will experience all sorts of reactions and
symptoms that have been come to known as a Herc cyber reaction.
So what could you do about it?
You have to just go slower with your treatment.
So slower with your treatment means either you run less time on the program or you move the
bulb farther away from you so there will be less effect on your body.
So I have had some Lyme patients actually have to put the machine in the bulb in the adjacent
room because they react so severely.
But typically if you put it the other side of the room, but if you cover it with the pillow
in the bulb, of course you are going to have some, it is going to go through the pillow
but it is going to disperse some farther you get away from the bulb, the less treatment
effect it will have on your body.
So those are the things that we recommend.
Next question.
Wow.
I wish I had never done the Zyto scan.
So this is a person who did a Zyto scan at another clinician's office or office, but
Zyto scan is one of those little instruments where you put your hand on this scanner and
then in five minutes it tells you everything that's wrong with you.
Now I say that a little facetiously because I mean that a little facetiously.
I am not the biggest fan of Zyto scan so let's finish the question.
The pesticide numbers came back shockingly high.
Our home has all hardwood floors, three in-home air purifiers, all-house water filtration system,
all-done toxic cleaning and cosmetic products.
The only explanation of the scanner, I think the person who did the scanning and was that
we live near a park even though my husband did not show these safe results only me.
And pesticides can travel up to two miles.
I've inclined to take this with a grain of salt.
Of course they're the products that this person recommended.
Some of them are already on and some I would not touch with the 10-foot pole any thought
stocked or see.
Plus the live numbers were high.
So number one I think Zyto scans are fine to give you an idea that you might something
might be going on, but I would never ever, ever nor to think that it's appropriate to give
a person a diagnosis based upon a Zyto scan.
Then why would you do it?
Yeah, I don't know, good question.
So maybe as an indicator that let's say if you did a Zyto scan and it came back super high
and pesticides, then maybe that would spark me to do a toxicity, you're a test.
And that's what I would use as my data.
So remember, any test that's out there, whether it be a physical exam, a neurological exam,
a CT scan or a PET scan or a regular blood test, all these things give you clues.
Same thing with a Zyto scan, it gives you clues.
That's all it gives you.
You cannot diagnose off a Zyto scan.
Honestly, I think it's not only inappropriate, I think it's borderline male practice.
I just don't think it's that accurate.
So the second thing is, if it is accurate, it's picking up frequencies.
So if you picked up the frequency of a pesticide, does that mean you have that pesticide?
No, it doesn't.
So I'm not a fan, so I would do it and I would be inclined as well to take this with
a great assault.
The only reason, again, why I would do it is maybe in a screening setting to see if I should
do further testing.
You do not diagnose off a Zyto scan.
Having positive pesticides, quote, unquote, show up on your Zyto scan, does not mean you have
pesticides in your body.
Having positive lime show up on a Zyto scan does not mean you have lime in your body.
So then why would you do it?
I don't know.
So I would just toss it myself, sorry.
Next question.
When my doctor, Rad Bloodwark, he said that I have low thyroid because my TSH was slightly
elevated.
Should I increase my thyroid medication based upon that?
No, no, you shouldn't.
So I see this a lot.
The person gets a blood test from their practitioner and they run a thyroid testing and they, well,
they tell the person that they read a thyroid test and all they read is a TSH.
So understand, TSH is thyroid stimulating hormone.
It's not secreted by your thyroid.
It's secreted by your pituitary because your hypothalamus senses your level of thyroid hormone
in the blood.
Well, what is that?
Well, you have free T3, which is the active thyroid hormone in the blood and that's what
sensed.
If it is low, it will tell the pituitary to secrete thyroid stimulated hormone to get your
thyroid to stimulate, stimulate it to secrete more hormone.
The thyroid secretes thyroid hormone primarily in the four, what's called T4, 95% of what's
secreted is in T4, 5% is in the active form of T3, while T4 will then convert to T3 in the
gut and in the liver.
So sometimes when a person does have low thyroid, technically low thyroid is defined by having
low T3.
So if a person has low free T3 and low total T3, then you would look at why?
It can be because of a conversion problem, maybe they have high or high normal T4 and it's
not converting to T3.
Well, then you've got to fix the person's gut and work on the person's liver.
That could also give a person an elevated TSH.
So again, you would give the person more thyroid hormone based upon elevated TSH alone.
If the person had elevated TSH, low T3 and low T4, then they probably need an increase in
their dose of thyroid medication.
But if by just doing a blood test and showing TSH alone, without running the rest of a full
thyroid profile, again, I'm sorry, but this is like
this bothers me because this is bad practice, we'll just say bad practice.
It's just wrong.
It's not getting a good evaluation of what's going on, sorry, but it's just not good doctrine.
Love it by a person, a person who asked this question, our friend had the scanner brought
it to our house and ran the test.
I just apologize, I don't want to mean anything mean to your friend or anything, but I just
don't think they're, they can be good for scanning to see, oh, maybe I should test them
do a proper test, like a blood test or a urine test, a laboratory.
That's an accredited, clear approved lab, it's hard to get that accreditation and they're
using proper machinery to run your tested, then that I would say, then you could use it
for that purpose, but you don't diagnose off as I don't scan.
You just don't, it's just not, that is, that is not correct, that's not right practice.
As much as it's not right practice to diagnose a low thyroid, not a TSH level, there's
a lot of practitioners, maybe the majority of practitioners, medical doctors, and alternative
practitioners that do not understand how to manage thyroid cases, I don't say that
arrogantly, it's just, I've had a lot of training, it's been all my money, going to school.
But you got to do it, if you want to do it, it's right for people, I just, I don't get it,
I'm sorry.
Next question, what is the best test to show me if my cancer is stable or in revision?
Well, there isn't a best test, it's a collaboration between many tests, so you know, you
want to, you know, you go from the most invasive like a PET scan or a CT scan to the lesser side of
invasive this, maybe an MRI to go down that pathway of lesser invasive this ultrasound to the
blood work. So, I don't want to do another PET scan, but I feel like I'm doing real well, so you,
the objective side of that testing would be blood work, and you look at the blood work as a whole,
so you look at, if I have known metastasis, that I would look at alkaline phosphatase,
calcium levels, liver, other liver function tests, kidney function tests, look at anemia numbers,
those are in the blood test you would look for things like that, and then you could look at if you
showed positive tumor markers in the past, you could use that as a, as a, you know, a helpful
indication of whether you're going in the right direction or the wrong direction, but there
isn't any one test that's going to say, yes, I'm in remission or yes, I'm doing greater, or the opposite
have, oh no, I'm doing much worse, you take each test gives you clues, so you take as many
data points as you possibly can and you formulate a decision, clinical decision making process,
plus you add subjective findings into that as well, so that's how you make the best differential
diagnosis, that's how you best make the best clinical decisions, you know, I talked to somebody today
who they should, it was an alternative oncologist's person is going to, so they are recommending a
pill that this person is on, and then they did a DNA test on the person of the DNA circulated to
her cell levels were elevated, therefore they said the oncologist said your cancer is getting worse,
we need to increase and put you on a platinum based medication chemotherapy, because the cancer
is getting worse and I was like, well hold on a second, what was the other data, was it solely based
upon circulated to her cells increased, and this person wasn't for sure, but said yes, because they
had just had a CT scan and CT scan was normal, there was no growth, and she said her blood work was
all under control, well, it's like okay, we can't make major clinical decision making
based upon one piece of data, I still think that's correct, I don't think that's fair to the patient,
I mean yeah, if you're gonna change their supplements or something like that, but if you're telling
them to go on a medication that could alter their life forever, based upon one piece of data,
when other data show that they're doing well, I just don't think that's proper practice,
it sounds like the entire Zoom call here, I'm kind of grabbing about other practitioners and I don't
mean to do that, but I want you to be wise enough to to discern what is going to be right
care for you, because you're going to other practitioners, so I'm trying to help you discern these things,
so best test to show me if I cancer stable, there isn't one, you look at all sorts of data points,
so doing blood work, doing scans, doing MRIs, looking at subjective data, that's how the best way
to know if you're going down the right path. Next question, why do oncologists not recognize any
benefits of other care? I wouldn't necessarily agree with that, I think there are a lot of oncologists
that do recognize the benefits of other care, but from a medical legal standpoint, their
hands are tight, unless they have their own private practice, they have to follow the guidelines
of the practice that they belong to, or the healthcare system that they belong to, or they will be
in trouble, so they can't recommend supplements, they can't recommend hypermectant, they can't recommend
right machines, they can't recommend Ben Benazone, they would get into trouble, so they are
products of the system that they belong to, and in order to not live with that mental disconnect,
they have to basically buy into what they're doing, or it's just not healthy mentally for them,
so that's what happens, so I do think there's a lot of good oncologists out there that want
what's best for their patients, and if you don't feel like you have one, I suggest maybe look for
somebody else. Dr. Brady wants Kathy to start taking multi-college and protein after her cell
treatments is it's okay to add other stuff that you have, that you other than what you have around,
so this is a person talking about their wife who does not have cancer, who's getting treatment from
a different doctor friend of mine who's doing something that we don't do, and so that's what this
question is about, stop cancer questions, so the answer would be yes, yes, that would be just fine
for her to do, yes. Okay questions from the chat, how do I address frequent night
urination? Well frequent night urination for a male is typically due to prosthetic enlargement,
so prosthetic enlargement can be what's called benign, prosthetic enlargement,
meaning that it's not due to cancer, so if you don't have prostate cancer but you are getting up
and going to the bathroom you know five times a night, it can be because you're not completely
emptied, you're bladder, and yet you're getting the sensation that you have to pee and it's waking
you up, so you're waking up to go to the bathroom and you're not completely emptied your bladder,
because your prostate is enlarged pinching on the exit of that urine, so you have
uritors that come from your kidney down to your bladder, and then your bladder goes
has a tube called your urethra that goes down to empty into the toilet, but it passes through your
prostate, prostate is enlarged, then you it will block that, so you won't get full emptied of
your bladder. Number two reason why you could get having to go to the bathroom all the time
can be because of blood sugar issues, so people with diabetes tend to have to get up and go to the
bathroom a lot, or in a pre-diabetic state, so getting checking your blood sugar, getting a simple
glucometer to check your blood sugar would be a good idea to make sure that you're not in a pre-diabetic
state, because that could be a possibility of why you're having to get up to go to the bathroom.
Number three, so again how do you address frequent diet urination, you try to address the cause,
so I said benign prosthetic hypertrophy would be one cause, prostate cancer with
increased size of the prostate would be another cause, talking males there only, pre-diabetic or
diabetes would be a third cause both males and females, fourth cause could be an urinary tract
infection, so urinary tract infections can cause that because you got inflammation at your
retra many times in the bladder, that could cause that issue. You can as we age another condition
that's not very commonly spoken about is what's called a tipped bladder, very common with women
with a tipped uterus, the bladder and the uterus will all tip forward. If it tips forward, it's hard
to show you without using my hand signals that I'm using right now that you can't see, but if
if the bladder tips forward then it can pocket like a little pocket of the anterior or front side of
the bladder where it doesn't empty because the your retra that is the tube that empties the bladder
is now tipped backwards, it is higher than a little bulge of the bladder, so you're never really
emptying the bladder completely, so a tipped bladder with women it goes with a tipped uterus is another
issue, I used to do that a technique where you tipped the uterus back and tipped the bladder back,
I don't think I have a video of that, maybe I should make a video, create a video because you could
do it to yourself but you could have somebody do it to you and that could bring that could possibly
bring a lot of relief, so you're trying to figure out the cause, whatever you're saying okay,
I have this symptom, what could that symptom be, what could be causing that symptom, so you could
treat the cause of that, so those would be the most common things, drinking, being excessively
hydrated before you go to bed, some simple things like that could be other causes, but trying to dig
to figure out that cause would be the answer, to know if you have a possible urinary tract infection,
you could actually, and I've recommended people do this, you could actually go on Amazon and you
could get urine dipstick tests, same literally, the same test that if you went and got a blood test,
they also did a urine analysis on you and you had to give a urine sample, they literally take those
dipsticks, test with strips which you could buy them for maybe a dollar, a test strip or even less
than that, cause the little thing that you buy on Amazon, the test of urinary strips, make sure you get
the one with the most amount of tests on there, you dip it in your urine, so you collect a urine sample,
you dip that strip of the urine and then you follow the instructions on the little cylinder that it comes
with and then you look at the colors of each test against the cylinder itself and you could tell
if you have any possible, make sure you get the one that has a bacteria tested it, so if you have
an infection or a high glucose or something like that, you could get an idea of what's going on
urinary tract wise. Okay, next question from the chat, I have scar tissue from having a
lift trip seat for kidney stones, so I thought it may be good to run the rife program for scar
aid, so I suppose I should place the bulb close to the scar tissue in my abdomen from the left kidney
area. Yes, so if you're treating a specific problem like that, I have scar tissue or let's say I have
a bladder infection, where should you put the bulb, we'll put it right next to the bladder,
so that would be another thing, the person that asked the question about the frequent night
urinary tract, you could literally run bladder infection or viral programs or something like that
and put the bulb right next to your bladder and see if that helps as well. So yes,
whenever you're treating something specific, for a short day program, it's always best to put
the bulb is close to the spot that you're treating as that would be the best treatment.
Next question, I found a gluten-free bread that I can stand, yeah, that's truth, but it has
cultured cane, sugar cane, sugar salt and other things that don't sound good, all the gluten-free
breads seem to have the same stuff, throw it or keep looking. There isn't even any bread that's
not going to sugar in it, so unless you are making your own bread, you're not going to,
I think it's a benefit having cane sugar and cultured cane sugar versus having
high fructose corn syrup that probably is in other cheaper breads. So I would say go ahead and
use it, you're just not like you're eating a loaf of bread every day or maybe eating a couple pieces
every couple days or something like that. As far as brands of gluten-free bread that I like, I like
Canyon, I don't know if you can get that where you're at, but Canyon, I can't remember the name,
if that's the full name of it, but that is it, I like that, I think that's a decent gluten-free bread.
Next question, my ferritin is 37 and total iron is 107 in a blood test done on February this year.
You told me that my foot cramps may be from low iron. Do I have to take any kind of iron if yes,
which one? Well, I wouldn't give you, I'm just saying, I've answered a question based upon what
could cause cramping. So low minerals, low iron, those are the things that can be a cause
of cramping, but I wouldn't, as a person with cancer, I wouldn't use iron unless I had other
signs of anemia. So I wouldn't recommend a cancer patient, use iron if they solely based upon
their total iron and their total ferritin, because honestly, your total iron of 107
is within normal range. So optimal range of total iron is like 85 to 130, so it's like perfect.
Your ferritin is within normal range, too. So I wouldn't based upon those lab findings give you
total, I wouldn't give you iron. Your ferritin might be a little bit low based upon optimal range,
but you're definitely in standard lab range with ferritin. And then the other thing, the person with
cancer has to be careful with iron, is that cancer had gobbled up iron. So we'd only give iron if
the person showed signs of anemia, low hemoglobin, low hematocrit, low red blood cell count,
and low total iron. So we would jump to that. Yeah, I just, I wouldn't jump to that. Next question,
what supplement can I use to address this? And this is the question that you asked before,
the frequent night urination. Well, again, it doesn't, you have to find, we have to figure out the
cause of that. So based upon just saying, we have to be careful not to use supplements like medical
doctors use medicine. And I say that because I think a lot of practitioners do that, and again,
not to just bash practitioners again, but your, your, you know, there's not necessarily just a
supplement for every symptom. So a symptom is a sign that something is going on. So again, we want
to figure out what the reason that your body is giving that sign, or what is the cause of that
symptom, and then treat that. So there's a lot of possibilities to, you know, frequent night
urination. Now you're saying that your blood sugar is usually below 100. So it's probably not
diabetes type things. But it's, you know, with a male, and a male that's over 55, the most
common reason for night urination is going to be benign, prostatic hypertrophy. So we should probably
get, have a phone call, and then we can discuss some things that you're currently on. I can't look at your
current protocol at this point, but you'd think of some things that would decrease the swelling of
the prostate. And typically the supplements that you'd use for that would not interfere with any
form of cancer than a person would have. So, and so we could, we could, we should have a phone call
and discuss that. Any other questions? Oh, you are very welcome, everybody. All right, well then we'll
call it a night. Hopefully this one will be this one will be saved with, you know, get this recording up.
All right, God bless everyone of you, and we'll be knowing that we're praying for all of you, and
and again, we mind everybody to be praying for everybody else. All right, bye-bye.